is bitcoin the ultimate meme like has
bitcoin risen to the hall of fame of
memes and built a trillion dollar asset
off the back of uh kind of a medic
desire the hall of fame of memes man i
like that uh i think so i mean i i don't
i can't come up with a better one off
the top of my head and you know part of
that i think is satoshi you know he's
like he's the the ideal kind of
mythological figure that we can project
all kinds of things onto
um you know there's in many ways there's
there's a religious element to all of
this because of that um because of kind
of you know the way that people talk
about their belief in it um so i do
think that it is is definitely in the
hall of fame of memes um
and i think that's probably i mean it's
not a good thing or a bad thing it's
just it is what it is but i think that
when you know bitcoin is in my opinion
it's in its early life right it's in 800
billion dollar asset class it could
become a 10 or 15 trillion dollar asset
class
so i think the question i like to ask is
at what point does the meme become less
important and does it start behaving a
little bit more like
um like a traditional asset class when
it's matured so right now i think it's
in the hall of fame in the memes i think
it would probably be good for bitcoin if
it became less of a meme um in the
future once it's a little more mature
and when you think about uh these
financial assets and memes uh you
mentioned religion and i jokingly
yesterday uh as i was preparing for this
i tweeted actually and i said uh the
decline of religion mirrors the rise of
meme assets or meme stocks uh and not so
much in like yes people are uh you know
leaving religion to go to the meme
stocks but it does feel like there has
been a replacement uh with memetic
desire for what used to be religion
right the uh studies show that people
are much less religious especially
younger people today than they used to
be
what's driving that or how do you look
at you know maybe religion and memetic
desire and then like other things that
might be replacing it today
i think i think that's right um i mean i
think that they are negative negatively
correlated um memetic desire is not a
negative thing let's be clear about that
from the beginning i think it operates
in a positive way in forming a sense of
community right you have people with a
shared desire i'm catholic okay so i'm a
pretty you know religious guy and i can
tell you that the the memetic desire
works in forming the community in the
church it always has
um you know i think about like my you
know the italian immigrants that were
coming over here like that that memetic
desire that mimesis for for that shared
object of desire and uh for that
community was a tremendously positive
thing i think that's happening a bit in
in this move digital finance you have
these communities forum and you have
daos you have discord channels and it is
in some sense um filling a need for a
sense of community with like-minded
people that quite frankly um the major
religions at least here in the united
states has not done a very good job at
that community aspect of them is lacking
i say that from first-hand experience so
i think people are filling in that need
in other ways i think that all human
beings are are just fundamentally
religious whether you that doesn't mean
that you're part of that you go to
church it just means i think that we're
religious beings by nature and that that
has to manifest itself in some way um
through some kind of search for
transcendence i think a lot of people
are finding it
in bitcoin and crypto in general